la semaine passée chez arrivé j'avais
des jurys but les chiffreurs sur la
grèce était comme hiver jacques du
rocher aime bien se promener sur cette
île qui l'a vu grandir
l'île sainte thérèse où son grand père a
bâti cette maison de ferme en 1912 à une
centaine de mètres de la rive
pour semblait d'accord on prenait une
grande course pour aller voir des
bateaux quand t'es battu 19 mais
aujourd'hui plus besoin de course et
entre la maison il arrive puisque un
mètre de terrain sombre dans le fleuve
chaque année et d'ici quelques années si
on ne fait rien ce sera aussi le cas de
la maison des du rachis ce serait la
disparition non seulement de la maison
mais de l'établissement de la famille
c'est dans les ricains qui depuis trois
ans à cette hauteur du fleuve il n'y a
pas que le nom de la famille du rocher
qui est menacée sur l'île des lauriers à
côté là où logent des dizaines de
milliers d'oiseaux vinyles sont emportés
toutes les semaines
puis en dernier et l'année les années
auparavant il y avait quelques arbres
c'est sur la pointe des armatures n'ai
pas pu lier votre âme et abriter l'un
des corps morts avec l'érosion est
complètement rob est entraînée par le
courant
francis st pierre et techniciens de la
faune et observe les oiseaux ici depuis
20 ans il observe aussi ceux qui leurs
ruches du terrain les vagues de bateaux
qui arrivent ils viennent carrément
frappé la côte frappé la côte la vague
rôle des bolides terrain que les
sédiments sera mars danseurs près de
4000 navires passent ici chaque année
ils ne sont pas les seuls coupables de
l'érosion le vent les bateaux de
plaisance n'est pas mais tout de même ce
sont leurs vagues qui font plus mal
alertés au début des années 2000 par
environnement canada le port de montréal
a demandé aux pilotes de ralentir entre
sorel il vieux port
selon les autorités portuaires 97% des
armateurs obéissent à cette mesure
volontaire et le port estime qu'il a
fait son travail mais cette mesure
semble bien dérisoire pour les amender
il
c'est le plus beau joyau du
saint-laurent les habitats naturels du
tout ce qui est perdu c'est perdu à
jamais ça revient de repos le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que les
véritables propriétaires semblent moins
inquiets aux relations publiques du
ministère des ressources naturelles qui
possède la majorité de l'île
sainte-thérèse
on n'était pas au courant du problème
environnement canada nous a dit avoir
transféré lui aussi à la sécurité
publique du québec qui elle-même nous a
envoyé aux municipalités
celle ci nous ont envoyé au ministère
des transports responsables la voie
maritime
et là non plus on ne savait pas trop
bref les sédiments qui polluent le
fleuve les populations d'oiseaux
menacées la maison du rocher le problème
de personne on a fait ça de déposer la
famille a elle même construit un petit
enrochements mais elle se demande que
font les gouvernements des grandes peurs
g on n'a pas laissé tomber encore mais
c'est désespérant